good morning believe nation today's
message is live your life with integrity
over to you Ellen DeGeneres when I was
younger I thought success was something
different I thought when I grow up I
want to be famous I want to be a star I
want to be in movies when I grow up I
want to see the world drive nice cars I
want to have groupies to quote the
Pussycat Dolls how many people thought
it was boobies by the way it's not it's
groupies but my idea success is
different today and as you grow you'll
realize definition of success changes
for many of you today success is being
able to hold down 20 shots of tequila
for me the most important thing in your
life is to live your life with integrity
and not to give in to peer pressure to
try to be something that you're not to
live your life as an honest and
compassionate person to contribute in
some way I think everybody wants to live
their life with integrity I think it can
be hard it can be challenging because
the devil always seems to come carrying
a bag cash right there's these
opportunities that you see that is
really the right thing to do but is
rewarding you know is easy they're
financially rewarding or it's or it's
rewarding in terms of you get social
recognition appreciation from the people
around you
and I think what really helped me is
identifying what it is that's my core
value right for me it's believed you can
figure what your one word is and what's
true to you and everything that I do I
see through the lens of belief and I you
know believe in entrepreneurs that's why
I made this channel so I'm making this
video and I've turned down six-figure
deals from brands because they didn't
buy into believe because they wanted me
just to pitch their product to promote
what they're up to but they didn't
really care about entrepreneurs and
that's a big deal to me and I would any
day of the week turn down those deals
even if it was you know needing cash
because it feels dirty you know it feels
like I'm being vile
you know to do things that are against
what is true to you
feels kind of masked and you want to try
to avoid doing that and I think it takes
a little bit of courage to build up the
muscle but the more you do it the easier
it is just like anything else you know
the more you lift weights of stronger
your muscle gets the more you make
decisions that are tough based on what
you believe to be true to you the easier
the next decision becomes to make and
the easier the next one isn't easier the
next witness so now you know brain comes
to me with a big deal it's easy to say
no to the first one might have been a
little bit harder to say no so I
encourage you to start building your
muscle right it doesn't have to be on a
great scale with some huge deal if
there's something that somebody's asking
you to do when you feel the peer
pressure to do it but it doesn't feel
right inside say no that might be
awkward and uncomfortable
but the next time will be easier and the
next one will be easier and the next one
will be easier and you'll feel happier
you will make a better contribution and
you'll be able to start living your life
on your terms not somebody else's
version of your life so the question
today today is I'm curious when your
integrity was challenged when you had to
make a really hard decision based off of
something that you felt was core to you
and whether you said yes or no to that
I'm really curious to find out share
your story please leave in the comments
below thank you guys so much for
watching have an amazing day continue to
believe and I'll see you again tomorrow
morning for another shot of interesting
ok
an espresso TV go